welcome back to welcome back to hannity
it was another day of controversy for
hunter biden
as his art show continues to raise
mounting ethics concerns
experts are now saying these amateur art
pieces some expected to sell for as much
as five hundred thousand dollars
are significantly overpriced and florida
congressman michael waltz
is set to introduce a bill aimed at
providing greater transparency into
hunter's secretive business dealings
requiring presidents and vice presidents
to provide
financial disclosures for their
non-dependent children
congressman walsh joins us now with the
latest along with fox news contributor
laura trump all right congressman waltz
first of all congratulations to you
because
they kept saying it's all fine no one
will ever know who's selling who's
buying who's paying
so kudos to you for at least thinking of
a bill what will your bill do
well you know hunter biden is he he's an
artist uh
he's a con artist he's the type of
artist he is
and and let's just review very quickly
his
masterpiece his gallery of corruption
that are full of masterpieces exhibit a
burisma
vice president biden then in charge of
reducing corruption in the ukraine
hunter biden on the board of one of the
most corrupt companies
in the country exhibit b china flies
with vice president biden
to china on official business on air
force two
and months later 1.5 billion
dollars invested partnered with the
central bank of china
and to this day judge to this day
is an equity holder in the chinese
nuclear supplier group which is
blacklisted
for trying to steal warhead technology
from the united states
and then of course exhibit c this you
know
absolutely corrupt uh new art business
uh enough is enough let's get to the
bottom of it
this bill would force disclosure i want
to know who's circumventing the law
and getting to the white house through
buying
this i i even put air quotes around art
well you know he he seems to be an
expert laura
at at being able to bring in money and
uh you know the laptop which he
certainly we all know was his
uh and he didn't deny it gives 10
percent to the big guy
you know as as a trump you know as as
congressman waltz was
walking through that with us i couldn't
help but think how the left tried to
make
every day hell for
president trump i mean what's your take
on how this family's been able to get
away with it
well it's i mean all of it is a shame
all of it is a sham
all of it is terrible for america and
congressman waltz's bill i think is a
great idea
unfortunately we have had to get here in
america you've got to force
uh transparency in the biden
administration because
no one knows who is buying these
outrageously priced
art pieces and by the way i didn't need
the experts to tell me
that they were overpriced judge i love
that whole part of it
but it's really sad because what what
the bill ultimately would do is
i guess for future non-dependents
of presidents it's going to vice
president it's going to force them to
disclose their financial information
this is like the one kid that can't
behave at recess
so the whole class has to get punished
but it would be nice to know what is
happening behind the scenes as
congressman waltz just walked through
we know that hunter biden has been
dependent on joe biden
and his position in government for many
many years and to the tune of millions
and billions of dollars of profit
for the biden family so hopefully we can
get to the bottom of this
he certainly had no experience that got
him the job at barisma
that was because his dad was vice
president certainly getting money from
china from russia all because his dad
was vice president
had nothing to do with his skill set
whatsoever
so would be nice to get to the bottom of
exactly what he's making all that money
for
and you know congressman walsh i i i
don't know about you but i really don't
have a lot of faith in the department of
justice getting to the bottom of
anything as as laura is saying i mean
she's absolutely right
we need to get to the bottom of it um i
don't know that the doj
will what do you think the chances are
of your bill getting passed
well you know i i agree with you on the
doj i mean the fact that he was under
investigation
during the 2020 election and the doj to
stay
unapolitical decided not to reveal any
of that well that was a political
decision
the american people deserve to know that
before they cast their vote
but i don't think we see this actually
move to be candid with you judge
until we fire nancy pelosi in 15 months
and send her back to her ice cream in
in california but i have to tell you
when we do take the majority
we are going to get to the bottom of
these business dealings
from the house of representatives
because what i want to know
is what kind of businesses are the
chinese directing hunter
to give them access to the chinese
communist party
isn't giving him a billion dollars to
buy a shoestring factory
in michigan they want robotics they want
advanced
uh materials they want artificial
intelligence
they want things their military can use
to then dominate the united states
and if there was a circumvention of our
export controls and trying to protect
that
ip that's what i want to get to the
bottom of and i think there's a lot more
shoes to drop here
well i don't think there's any question
there's a lot more shoes and and to drop
it but
lara you know the laura the last
question to you
i mean with respect to hunter biden and
the sales of this so-called art
i mean do you think we'll ever be able
to find out let's let's assume that the
bill doesn't pass
will we ever get to the bottom of that
or will they just be shoveling in
millions through that
that funnel called art
uh unfortunately we probably will never
know it'll be just like everything else
with the biden family cover-up after
cover-up
help of course from the dnc help from
the marketing arm for the democrat party
also known as the mainstream media we
will never
get to the bottom of this and
unfortunately it is terrible for america
what a bad
precedent something like this could set
and it's incredibly frustrating to see
because
as you know as i continue to say and you
continue to hear from our family
when my father-in-law was president we
went out of our way
to make sure that there was full
transparency we didn't have to do it but
we paid
every dollar that any foreign entity
spent at a trump property
back to the united states treasury
because we didn't want to have the
faintest
hint of impropriety when we wanted
everything to be above board
they still came after us they still
continue to come after president trump
the prosecutors out there in new york
are
absolutely disgraceful letting criminals
go
and yet going after donald trump and the
trump organization for nothing it is
absolutely outrageous sometimes it's
hard to recognize this country
as america congressman waltz laura trump
thanks so much
to both of you all right hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else